hay nuevos detalles sobre la posible
causa del bloqueo del canal de suez
aunque inicialmente la compañía dijo que
los fuertes vientos hicieron que el
portacontenedores ever given en callara
a lo largo del canal y bloquear a uno de
los principales caminos del comercio en
todo el mundo ahora las autoridades
sostienen que esto pudo haber ocurrido
por un error humano podría haber un
error humano que está bajo investigación
podría haber muchos errores pero ahora
no podemos decir cuáles son el único
error del que podemos estar seguros
ahora es el viento y la tormenta de
arena pero esta no es la principal causa
el resto se aclarará en la investigación
osama rabino dio una fecha estimada si
cuando podrán mover el portacontenedores
pero señaló que podría ser en los
próximos dos días el avance más grande
hasta ahora ocurrió el pasado viernes la
prueba de la embarcación se desenterró
un poco gracias a los remolcadores y a
las dragas que han removido más de
20.000 toneladas de arena y de barro
alrededor del buque dos remolcadores
adicionales llegarán el domingo y
mientras eso ocurre las autoridades del
canal de suez ya están pensando en
per nativas por si el plan original no
funcione es necesario tendremos barcos
con grúas para sacar los contenedores
uno a uno del barco encallado y ponerlos
en otras embarcaciones hasta vaciar toda
la carga más de 300 embarcaciones siguen
a la espera de atravesar el canal de
suez de lo contrario deben desviarse
hacia el sur de áfrica lo que implica
6000 kilómetros adicionales de recorrido
dos semanas más en el itinerario de
viaje y el aumento de los costos del
combustible eso explica el afán de mover
el gigantesco barco de 400 metros de
largo y solucionar el atasco que existe
desde el pasado martes